I'm dr. David Axelrod and I'm a
pediatric cardiologist here at Stanford
I'm David Starr
I run lighthouse which is a virtual
reality education company that I founded
about five years ago at a JSK journalism
fellowship at Stanford the Stanford
virtual heart is a virtual reality
congenital heart disease experience that
we built really to teach and train
students trainees and physicians at
Stanford and beyond and also for
patients and families to help understand
about congenital heart defects the
important challenge that we're
addressing with our project is that the
content is very three-dimensional
and teaching someone what's called
relational Anatomy which is this 3d
concept of where certain parts of the
heart are in relation to other parts of
the heart is really very difficult with
two dimensional structures and so for
years we've really asked trainees and
also patients and families to take these
two-dimensional pictures and construct a
3d image in their head we really needed
to add a rigorous pedagogy to these
virtual reality experiences in order to
make them really a strong learning
experience and that's a lot of what twt
helped us do was to sit and think well
you have this great resource for
learning but how do you build a
framework around it that's going to help
students and that's also going to be the
basis for virtual reality enhanced
teaching in the future right so the
current status of our virtual reality
heart project is that we have a core
subject matter of the actual content in
VR and we've now been able to create
really the beginnings of that blended
learning platform between virtual
reality and the online course content
the twt grant and workshop helped us
immensely we were able to you know
initially the first part of it really is
connecting with a number of leaders on
Stanford campus in various different
fields of expertise so whether that's
assessment or learning management
systems or you know the filming and
studio here at the VPT else to do so
those resources are really invaluable to
being able to develop the educational
pedagogy in our program